gentlemen ladies what if Superman had
decided to fly down rip off the roof of
the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office who would have stopped him
[Music]
I love this guy
not good
don't forget we're the bad guys are you
sweet-talking me all of that chit chats
gonna getcha
[Music]
songul yeah we say stuff yes I want to
see stop I was just trying to get you
there
no hard feelings all right we good beer
whiskey what am i 12 how about you have
stuff water that's a good idea
hey youtubers new Suicide Squad trailer
so let's break it down a whole bunch of
Batman's Superman stuff happening in it
too if we're gonna talk about Batman and
Superman in this trailer I'm gonna have
to talk about Batman V Superman in the
movie so just careful for spoilers from
that so here we go
is there talking about Superman it
sounds like he's still dead when this
movie picks up this does happen after
Batman V Superman I don't know if the
Batman scenes in this are entirely
representative of the amount that he's
in the movie like if it's a spider-man
situation and he's in like 30 minutes of
the movie or if it's much less than that
I think it's gonna be much less than
that we see him chasing the Joker in the
Batmobile so at some point he jumps from
car to car in the movie probably and we
see him diving off this pier so if you
really like the more acrobatic way
Batman moved in Batman V Superman and I
think most people did there's gonna be
more of that in this film so I think
it's gonna be really awesome and it
remains to be seen how much Batman
interacts with the suicide squads
mission or if they'll just run into each
other as they're independently trying to
take down the Joker and I think Amanda
Waller being who she is has an idea for
what's going on with Batman especially
with Superman because she's part of the
government task force X is a
government-funded team so while she's in
this White House briefing here she's
going to be one of those people that
isn't so hot on metahumans but is happy
to throw them under the bus when the
opportunity arises the rest of the new
footage from all the Suicide Squad
members in the trailer is really just
character building just expanding on
some of the scenes that we've seen
before rick flagg putting the team
together if you do anything wrong I'm
gonna kill you if you fart on me I'm
gonna kill you if you ask me why I'm
gonna kill you I'm gonna kill you Harley
Quinn with a Jersey accent this whole
bar scene that you see at the end of the
trailer is actually probably one of the
better examples of how they really
become this close-knit group despite the
fact that they are all certifiable
Diablo seems like the most normal one of
the bunch it's like oh you just better
better give me water better take it easy
tonight or I'll end up setting
everything on fire great line from
Deadshot when he says you all must be
joking it doesn't immediately cut to a
shot of the Joker but I like the way
they're playing with the dialogue I'll
be interested to see which scenes they
ended up reshooting we probably won't
find out till much much later but
they're just they're punching up some of
the bits in the movie so we're probably
getting a mix of jokes and funnier
action scenes like this with Harley
Quinn and Killer Croc really love the
team-up effort I always love it when
superheroes combine their powers there
was a version of that in the Captain
America trailer video that I just posted
where Scarlet Witch throws a Captain
America fast
all special Wolverine Colossus style
Harley Quinn with her mallet is actually
kind of a new 52 thing most of this film
is based on John Ostrander Suicide Squad
he is one of the first big writers he
was the one that really turned it into a
big thing a long time ago just DC
stuffing a bunch of b-list characters
they couldn't hold their own titles
together into this team-up comic book
that once john austrian tour started
writing turned into this really awesome
thing so if you want to read Suicide
Squad comics read his original run but
because Harley Quinn didn't come along
till much much later
she's only joined the Suicide Squad
recently by comparison so there's just
not as much really old-school material
because she wasn't even created til the
90s now the new favorite Deadshot tried
to rile up Diablo just to get him
started
sorry man just trying to get you going I
think assuming standard movie timeline
what it'll happen is is like we'll meet
all these characters they'll kind of
have their own agendas and by the third
act of the film they'll actually become
a team so they can take down whatever
the biggest villain is gonna be if
that's gonna be the Joker or the
tattooed man but this trailer jumps the
gun just a little bit like they're not
immediately gonna be super best friends
right when they start out nobody's gonna
trust each other but I'm guessing the
tattooed man is what brings them
together in the Joker will be the
spectacular evil villain of the movie
let me know in the comments who do you
actually think is going to be the main
villain of this do you think it'll be
the Joker or do you think it's gonna be
something else but if you guys didn't
see I just posted a new Avengers Captain
America civil war trailer there's just a
new trailer with the team the cap put
together at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron so they're like The Avengers 2.0
I just calling the New Avengers just to
make it easy while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for that new Captain America civil war
trailer and you can click here to learn
about power girl coming on the flash
season 3 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight